Christmas is so close you can smell it
right and that's how that's with the
help of Aroma retail a local company
creating scents for our businesses and
our homes so it is great to see you both
we've got the president Christina and
CEO Jim and you guys are a married
couple I did not know that you've got
the power couple here helping us you
know smell good in this in Las Vegas now
you guys actually all of your scents are
also on the Strip so can we talk about
that first because when we walk into
these lobbies and we take a deep breath
and we're like wow what is that smell
that's you guys that's so cool so let's
talk about that which ones can we which
one can we sniff on the Strip well this
is Asian Garden and it's the signature
scent for most MGM properties uh most
noticeable at the Aria I would say
that's that's where we hear it a lot
it's also our top seller because what's
special about this is it it uses a full
bouquet of very light florals for a nice
fresh mild clean smell with a very light
overlay of vanilla so it feels safe safe
and homey and that's what they wanted
they wanted something that was fresh
clean but still made people feel at home
and and feel safe of course now while I
smell this let's move on to the next one
another it's so familiar that's so cool
another very popular scent is our bright
sunshine bright Sunshine is very popular
because it just has everything it's got
the floral the Citrus the greens the
woods the herbals this is most commonly
smelled at Lowe's hotels okay yeah
that's just a good nice fresh clean
we've developed all of these uh scents
in-house and all the products that that
put out this wonderful scents I know
it's right here the actual Factory is on
the campus as well it's like a little
Santa's Workshop in there you guys
bringing everything right there let me
show you next one this is the Empire and
you'll smell this at Caesars okay a nice
luxurious rose garden and it's got the
whole garden the stone the leaves and of
course the rose petals how do you how do
you choose what scents go into
listen I guess you could say well that's
a great question yeah if if I'm working
on a scent for a specific client I want
to see their brand I want to know who
their Target demographic is you know
what I mean their own their own
Ambitions and then of course design of
the space is so important right because
scent completes that design so
everything just feels right but from
businesses to homes let's kind of a
quick overview of what you guys have
that people can purchase from your from
your store or online so a lot of a lot
of Resort type of scents we have a a
place collection let's call the place
collection from a bakery to a bookstore
to a flower shop there's also our mood
collection that takes us from all you
know set of different moods I mean of
course the seasons yeah they have a very
nice collection of seasonal with the
champagne cheers and other and you also
have the heavy Ultra you know the heavy
duty stuff too absolutely yes so you can
you can send it with the traditional
read diffusers candles room sprays but
also our our scent machines who put it
straight into the air program to your
liking it's amazing I can't wait to tell
you about these special holiday deals
that they do have so thank you to you
guys Aroma retail for sponsoring this
segment give them a call at
702-780-7370 or visit aromaretail.com so
let me tell you the special offer 15 off
site-wide through December with code
lvnow15 and you can scan that QR code
right there for their 12 deals of
Christmas thank you